par l'état monsieur lionel luca ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des finances et des comptes
publics
monsieur le ministre les collectivités
territoriales vote en ce moment leur
budget sous couvert d'économies et alors
que vous alourdissent et leurs charges
aujourd'hui avec les nouveaux rythmes
scolaires demain avec l'indicé
revaloriser des fonctionnaires voulaient
ponctionner pour la troisième année
consécutive à hauteur de quelque 3
milliards 700 millions d'euros mettant
ainsi en péril les services publics
rendus à la population et surtout les
investissements qui profite aux
entreprises locales et donc à l'emploi
avec une certaine arrogance voulait
faire croire qu'elles sont dépensières
alors qu'elle vote elle des budgets en
équilibre
dans le même temps où vous vous n'avez
eu de cesse de demander des délais de
grâce à bruxelles pour ne pas avoir
respecté justement vos engagements sur
la réduction des déficits de l'état
vous n'avez donc rien trouvé de mieux
que de faire les poches des
collectivités territoriales pour remplir
celles de l'état qui sont percés la
semaine dernière une rumeur à bruit que
le gouvernement pourrait différer ou
réduire la pollution supplémentaire
prévue en septembre 2010 est là encore 3
milliards 700 millions qui va
définitivement rendre bon nombre de
communes complètement exemple avec une
grande brutalité vous y avez mis fin
préférant réserver les quelques pseudo
recette de poche dit imprévus en cadeaux
électoraux d'un président déjà en
campagne
l'association des maires de france qui
rassemble tous les élus de tous bords
vous demande de surseoir à cette
nouvelle ponction qu'elles jugent
intenable alors monsieur le ministre
allez vous entendre les élus de france
où allez vous continuer obstinément à
les mépriser la parole et comme monsieur
christian eckert secrétaire d'état
chargé du budget merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur
député dans ma réponse précédente
monsieur le député j'ai pointé le fait
que les dépenses de fonctionnement des
collectivités locales avait fortement
réduit
je crois que c'était une demande assez
générale pour réduire la dépense
publique et j'ai salué l'effort de
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
et y compris des collectivités
territoriales si mesdames messieurs les
députés
cela a quelque chose à voir vous aviez
été inquiet d'autres aussi sur
l'ensemble des bancs sur les
conséquences d'une baisse des dotations
de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales
j'ai eu l'occasion de rappeler puisque
les comptes viennent de nous parvenir il
ya quelques jours que malgré la baisse
des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités territoriales dont je
rappelle qu'elle représente qu'un quart
de leurs recettes
le dynamisme des autres recettes des
collectivités territoriales a permis aux
recettes de l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales de progresser de 1 25%
les recettes des collectivités
territoriales et ils vont continuer de
progresser pour entendre mesdames et
messieurs les députés
il faut reconnaître l'hétérogénéité des
situations et en cela le gouvernement
est prêt à discuter avec l'association
des maires de france avec l'association
des départements de france avec
l'association des régions de france
parce que la situation des départements
n'est pas la même que celle des communes
et des intercommunalités
nous prendrons les dispositions pour que
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales puissent continuer à avoir
des budgets en équilibre
vous avez parfaitement raison mais ceci
dans un souci de maîtrise de la dépense
publique
merci la parole est à m